[Music]
okay soda was a short-lived product from
the coca-cola company that was released
to test markets in 1993 it was created
by Sergio Simon the man responsible for
cokes most well-known failure new coke
in the 80s coke did some market research
and discovered at least according to
them that coca-cola was the second most
well known term in the world
the first was the term okay shooting for
number one this was the starting point
for okay soda soda that was heavy on the
branding but aimed at a crowd that was
fed up with being over advertised to and
manipulated by marketing ironically
taking cues from the pop psychology of
the preceding decade such as Thomas
Anthony Harris's I'm okay you're okay in
the past few weeks certain documents
regarding okay soda have been
Declassified they concerned the
distinctive taste of okay here is one
let's document advertising has a clear
goal to get you to buy a product this is
often done by associating a feeling or
an ideal with the product but what is
the idea and the feeling is
disillusionment with modern advertising
campaigns can you subvert something and
achieve the same thing that what your
subvert achieves
why do you bring it up okay so does
marketing campaign still feels unique 14
years later it stood out in a world of
sensational advertising by being
distinctly and boldly unsent a tional so
many of you have asked is there any
quick way to measure my current level of
Okemos Brian Lenihan Koch's manager of
special projects told Time magazine it
under promises it doesn't say this is
the next great thing the soda cans were
drab shades of grey with the occasional
red they were covered with illustrations
from respected contemporary comic
artists quotes from the OK manifesto and
coincidences the cans had a 1-800 number
printed on them that you could call to
hear a number of pre-recorded messages
or to record your own testimonial or
story about okay soda thanks for being
such a devoted color of the okay hotline
please listen closely to this ok
coincidence selective especially for you
and people called it brisk air'll show
and during my vacation in Ellis friend
offered me food ok soda tear down that
was a neck for the earthquake eggs but
mostly kids more interested in fooling
around than buying soda but can
disillusionment sell can you really
reach young adults who feel bombarded by
excessive advertising by shoving tons of
advertising in their face about how
unaccessible when the feeling and idea
you're selling is that advertising
branding and even life are a little
meaningless telling people that they'll
get that feeling by buying your product
might turn out to be a dead end it was
almost a weird attempt at reverse
psychology maybe ok soda was ahead of
its time today we are much more
comfortable with meta self-critical
advertising a study of Super Bowl
commercials from 1969 to 2009 concluded
that use of postmodern advertising
devices such as surreal visuals symbolic
associations and humorous juxtapositions
has been increased during the last four
decades look down
we're on you're on a boat we need a big
commercial hello ladies look at your
panda now look at me I'm on a tiger
customers rate these types of ads more
positively recently sprite launched a
new ad campaign that over 20 years later
feels like it's taking a play from the
okay so the playbook I never tell you to
drink sprite even if I was in a
commercial for sprite which I am for you
were watching which you are I would tell
you to drink it no matter what that cute
car said promise I know but I think
there's a distinction to be made here
between using clothes modern elements in
your advertising what many have called
postmodern advertising and founding an
entire brand around truly postmodern
ideas as okay so does seem to do total
its main concern for the past two weeks
a chain letter promoting okay so that
has run on local TV despite a huge
outpouring of support there have been
detractors notably Americans met out
okay they have compared our campaign to
a virus and to the notorious kudzu plant
creeping everywhere strangling all it
touches needing only dirt to survive it
seems postmodern elements can be most
effectively used to remove strict brand
associations allowing customers to
project more of themselves onto the
brand instead of trying to live up to an
idealized image FedEx is determined to
have the best commercial on the
Superbowl true post-modernism however
eats at the very core of what
advertising is advertising is aim is for
you to choose one product over another
or to get you to spend your money here
instead of somewhere else doing this
requires a value system that the
customer can use to judge the value of
the product the postmodernist view of
dismantling this value system is in
direct conflict with advertisings goal
so while the occasional postmodern
commercial or brand might succeed
because adopting those ideas allows it
to stick out from the noise and look
different I think postmodern ideas can
never be adopted by advertising
wholesale or it will end up eating its
own tail postmodern advertising
now usually only lightly pokes fun at
advertising instead of trying to sell
you on being fed up with it all together
and it explode no just a cabin no
explosions no explosions a brand usually
doesn't go so far as to say as okay soda
did in its manifesto what's the point of
okay well what's the point of anything
cards against humanity' is perhaps a
single current example of true
post-modernism and advertising that I've
found there a brand whose advertising
seems to attack the very idea of
advertising itself running a potato for
a Superbowl commercial and getting
people to donate money towards digging a
giant hole in the ground for no reason
but they're a company built around
making people laugh and being funny and
they give their game away partially for
free so there's less of an opportunity
to accuse them of hypocrisy harnessing
the negative emotions of a group or a
movement has proven tricky for brands
when pushing their products but maybe if
okay soda had been a start-up company
not an all new a one of the largest
brands on earth it would have been more
successful or maybe it was simply that
the soda tasted terrible reportedly like
a mix of coke dr. pepper root beer and
arm soda and no amount of clever
branding can sell a beverage to people
who don't actually want to drink it
recently authorities have asked old Kate
soda to respond to allegations that the
television chain letter is some sort of
secret code
nothing could be further from the truth
it is a marketing tool only a secret or
code of any kind would be
counterproductive it would imply that
okay is only for those who truly
understand it please stop this rumour
and help others to realize that things
are going to be okay I'm Thomas light I
hope you enjoyed this essay I've got
ideas for other essays like this so I
might do more of them if you guys seem
to enjoy them if you liked this essay
you might enjoy the podcast I do with my
friend then called obscure egami
it's a pointlessly educational podcast
about obscure things search of secure
gommi wherever you find your podcasts or
on youtube thanks again for watching I'd
appreciate it if you subscribed and I'll
see you all again next time